[Musique]
et
bonjour dit vous êtes l'invité de ce
pays grp et donc pendant une quinzaine
de minutes on va discuter à apprendre à
vous connaître je vais commencer par
vous présenter vous êtes un rappeur qui
a émergé dans le milieu du rap il ya
environ deux ans un peu plus de deux ans
ici on à poissy dans votre quartier
d'ailleurs et ça représente quoi pour
vous ici cb merci déjà merci pour
l'invitation c'est là que je suis né
c'est là que je suis c'est là que j'ai
grandi et bon comme tout à chacun je
pense que voilà que c'est mon coin 30
basket ici vous avez joué vous avez
pratiqué le terrain et cela et j'ai joué
j'étais assis à côté à écrire des trucs
moi je suis pas je suis moi basketteurs
de l'équipe mais j'ai passé du temps ici
et ce dont vous avez fait le buzz grâce
à des free style d'environ une minute
que vous faisiez en bas de chez vous
vous avez à votre actif un album tout va
sorti en mars 2021 de p4 ciom sorti en
octobre dernier crée en compagnie du
beatmaker nisy 0 qu'est-ce que vous
souhaitez véhicules et avec ses projets
justement ce projet notamment calcium
véhiculer humeur ouais je pense que
c'est ça surtout ouais je pense que
c'est ça surtout beaucoup calcium c'est
vraiment on l'a fait juste après l'album
l'album il a mis du temps à sortir par
rapport aux convives tous à machin donc
derrière vu qu'on avait attaqué sur ses
morceaux là avec nous on était super
content de refaire un truc derrière ce
qu'il avait déjà 4 prod sur l'album et
ouais c'est le projet pour avant d'aller
au boulot pour la pause déjeuner c'est
le petit format moi j'aime bien ce truc
là tu essayes des trucs que forcément tu
étais serpente mettant la pression
l'arrivée aucune pression c'était
parfait on voit quand vous rappelle
notamment même dans les photos à chaque
fois qu'on voit vous souriez ouais
j'suis un met de bonne humeur
et derrière sur les six pay duty enfin
c'est city 2 le p vous en avez clip et 3
dont le dernier plus ou moins qui est
sorti il ya deux semaines je vous
propose de regarder un petit extrait
richardson qui donne de plus en plus de
ma vie jour de moins en moins lui seul
de plus en plus de mauvais tours de
moins en moins d'immeubles de plus en
plus de fenêtres ouvertes dit jacky
points mineurs 2 milliards plus ou moins
d'une heure de plus en plus de matches à
rien et bijoux - qui s'activent ça de
faire des clips
oui mais voilà le dernier avec dj djel
ouais bah ouais ce qui est dj djel et ça
fait trop plaisir en plus ça le ferait
au de lusine dj ahidjo qui dans le
cliché tout donc ça fera plaisir mais
euh
non c'est un exercice auquel je me
presse parce qu'il nous faut ce n'est
pas pour me déplaire à la bâche qui
fascine chez tout pour ça que c'est à
chaque fois des trucs un tant soit peu
scénarisé moi ça me va c'est cool ça me
voit et il ya peu de temps je discutais
avec un rappeur saint quentinois kirtas
qui avait placé dans un de ces freestyle
ou par l'est où il parlait d'autres
artistes yvelines mans un truc du style
je crois que c'était bien il a un haut
débit comme dj va pas tu vois ses chats
je crois que ça j'ai entendu cela je
crois que ça je l'entendis je crois
qu'il avait envoyé moi ce gentil doux ça
c'est gentil de houphouet c'est ça votre
site voila c'est le haut débit rap un
peu oui il ya des morceaux je mitraille
mais je trouve ya des morceaux je
mitraille pas quand même que maintenant
ça y est je côtoie des mitraillettes
donc bon non non il ya des aléas des
morceaux je mitraille mais je ne sais
pas si le terme et mitraillettes c'est
la meilleure façon de définir en vrai je
sais pas trop je pense que si tu dis ça
il devait se voir les mecs qui vont être
déçus répondu je n'en sais quoi qui
courent haillicourt pas parce que dans
ce que vous allez faire par exemple on
voit dans le morceau ce simili ouais
c'est le jeu avec les répétitions c'est
un truc les tricks de répétition ça
c'est vrai que j'en fais beaucoup
maintenant c'est vrai que maintenant
qu'on me qu'on me signale oui c'est vrai
non mais c'est vrai que j'en fais
beaucoup ton similaire arrive à son
simili terme des simili 16 me font
l'effet dans ces mini putt du simili
week pour moi déjà simili des simili des
caraïbes le
freestyle bégaiement dans simili
d'indépendants avec des si avec virus
ouais non j'en fais beaucoup mais bon
j'aime bien j'aime bien je fais vraiment
le truc instinctivement et c'est un truc
qui me fait marrer instinctivement ou
que je fais commencez votre quotidien
'aujourd'hui de rappeur comment ça se
déroule votre vie artistique vous
écrivait des textes vous allez en studio
c'est bah c'est ça lala lala en ce
moment c'est essentiellement ça vu que
les scènes les ont pour l'instant été
toutes reportées à cause du coc vide
machin donc là pour l'instant c'est
essentiellement ça mais c'est trop bien
c'est trop bien en studio vous
travaillez justement avec une prod avec
midi le beatmaker c'est important de
faire écouter de faire lire vos textes à
d'autres gens pour créer de bonnes
musiques pour vous
les textes bas les textes en vraie voix
les textes c'est moi qui ai vraiment le
nez dedans à fond pour l'épreuve je fais
totalement confiance anizy pour les
mitch fais totalement confiance à locaux
et honnêtement je suis vraiment
spectateurs de ce qu'ils font dans le
sens où j'ai rien à j'ai vraiment rien à
dire à chaque fois c'est tu vois donc
bon mais l'a pour l'instant j'ai pas de
je suis pas je suis pas en mode
direction dans les studios moi je suis
en mode soldats comme tout le monde on
va faire en sorte que la bataille soit
belle mais il n'y a pas de général et on
dire un peu que vous êtes arrivé d'un
coup sur le milieu du rap ça fait il ya
deux ans bah ouais on va te battre
humain doit commencer en vidéo le veau
freestyle commence à ses fils de le
déclic qu'est ce qui vous a fait
basculer en fait dans le milieu c'est
les gens c'est les gens moi honnêtement
j'ai toujours un peu de façon récréative
pour moi et pour mes potes et pour voilà
comme ça uniquement pour le kiff de le
faire parce que je kiffe ça vraiment
j'ai un vrai vrai passionné d'opéra
j'écoute beaucoup de mecs et voilà mais
n'ont jamais de la vie je me suis dit
que je me suis dit que j'en ferai
quelque chose mais voilà par la force
des choses il a fallu que j'en fasse
quelque chose donc parce que les
freestyles prix et qui a beaucoup de
gens qui m'ont dit tu justement ils
voulaient que j'aille en studio et que
là pour le coup j'avais plus d' excuse
même vis-à-vis de tous les potes a qui
disent je regardais les chansons cesse a
dit roy
revenons sans fourtoy donc je suis
toujours en mode nous on s'en fout on va
le faire moi pour moi l'important c'est
vraiment la zik
s'il s'avère que il m'a il a ici c'est
vrai que je devrais retourner en
bâtiment en faire tout seul dans mon
coin je serai toujours aussi content
d'en faire moi mais là c'est trop bien
parce que là je peux partager le truc
avec plein de mecs que j'écoute depuis
super longtemps je rencontre plein de
gens super viande les concerts c'est une
rencontre que les vrais gens là ça fait
graver plaisir ce qui me donne ça fait
deux ans que j'attendais de les voir ils
voyaient là il n'y a pas le droit donc
là je peux enfin voir les gens et moi ça
fait plaisir de pouvoir enfin mettre des
visages sur tous les messages que je
reçois depuis ça c'est trop bien
aujourd'hui vous vivez durable j'ai
arrêté de bosser ça faisait 15 ans que
je bossais dans un magasin après sillage
arrêté mais
moi je conçois que moi je vois plus le
truc en mode je vais aller gagner ma vie
sur scène la zik gens n'attendent pas
grand-chose en vrai mais par contre les
concerts oui là oui forcément je vais
gagner ma vie sur scène donc là pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de scène donc
mais ça va venir ouais mais deux mais
oui quelque part je vis un petit peu
durable dans le sens où c'est tout ce
que je fais en ce moment
que je suis chez moi je vais te fait
dire à fond donc ouais et on va en
parler mais pour notre chaîne télé je
crois qu'il faut qu'on conduit ouvre une
sorte de séquences sans gros mots la
chanson fdp ouais pourquoi je suis mais
moi je fais attention
pourquoi la chanson fdp parce que ça à
l'époque je sais ce que j'ai
en gros c'est un client qui a quitté le
magasin à l'époque justement où je
bossais eux à poissy et il a quitté le
magasin en m'insultant et suite à cette
insulte vu que moi je suis resté quatre
heures après derrière à apposer voilà
rugby détruit j'ai commencé à écrire ce
truc là en mode de 6e degré et ça fait
marrer mes potes au quartier et du coup
j'ai mis de côté et puis un jour je suis
tombé sur la prod de fred qu'il a sur
youtube justement et je trouvais que
c'était marrant quoi mais du coup j'ai
fait ça mais vraiment
il n'ose amour parce que les elle a fait
le tour des réseaux sociaux moi sur
twitter j'ai vu c'est presque devenu un
mème en fait les gens il répondait à
d'autres gens voient là dessus cette
romance ah ouais moi tu prends ma blague
et tu fais des blagues avec moi soit tu
restes on reste dans le domaine de la
blague seulement on n'est bon ni quel
est donc dit qu'est ce qui arrive là
pour vous qu'est ce que vous nous
réservez dans les prochaines semaines
les prochains mois ah bah moi j'espère
j'espère vraiment faire de plus en plus
de son effet que les sons soit
j'ai dit de mieux en mieux mais moi je
suis super content déjà vote ce que je
fais c'est toujours bon serre c'est ça
surtout là c'est ça surtout la faute de
mieux on est en studio on essaye d'être
eu content des matches on enregistre des
trucs parce que c'est parce que c'est
trop mis en joie
et puis mais là je veux tellement faire
des concerts si j'ai eu tellement faire
des concerts l'album entre l'album et le
psg du fer 7 800 à tout casser et
souvent dans des conditions un peu
bizarre parce que tu vois la situation
l'imposé donc la whey de vivre les vrais
concerts en situation normale en vrai
ouais dans votre premier album vous avez
un clip qui s'appelle banzaï enfin un
musée s'appelle banzaï d'ailleurs pareil
on voit un écouteur un petit extrait au
sinistre en
[Musique]
thaïlande parmi les vacances histoire et
pourtant je suis un clown mais tout
n'est pas si gentil ça
j'suis un peu n'est en tout cas pas si
gentil
samantha l'espérance de vie
et pourtant c'est pas mon but banzaï
c'est une musique on dirait que vous
arrivez justement c'est la musique que
vous dites moi c'est moi voilà en fait
volteface et moi dans le sens où
maintenant c'est justement vu que
j'étais sur l'album vu que je voulais
absolument essayer de faire des morceaux
qu'ils soient un tant soit peu construit
parce que je suis vraiment très très
freestyle dans ma tête et s est pas j'en
suis fier mais j'adore ça en vrai en
vrai si c'est plus freestyle c'est plus
web donc fallait qui est vraiment un
morceau cour de récré et ça c'est mon
morceau cour de récré 0 calcule rien on
prend la prod anizy c'est le premier
truc qui parasitent le joker c'est donc
vous écrivez tout le temps free style
chez vous après vous voyez en fait ce
qui va bien je peaufine les puzzles à
mort à la maison en bois qui aime tous
les jours
donc maintenant je fais ça je fais ça je
fais ça constamment et on va dire qu'en
g34 puzzle dont je suis vraiment content
journal c'est bien là la touche plus bas
à ce moment là je vois si à moins
d'aller au studio pour voir comme voir
ce que ça donne parce qu'on sait jamais
hein moi des fois j'ai des idées je suis
pas l'ambassadeur
et sa dans le milieu du rap justement il
ya beaucoup de leçons en fit est ce que
vous voyez venir avec un dos freestyle
sur afida rappeur d'un gros rapport par
exemple nationale internationale
moi je moi je fais je fais déjà
décollage j'ai fait un saut avec cassen
j'ai fait un saut avec virus j'ai faim
sont avec avec dans votre cas je suis
sur l'album des svinkels
fx est quelque chose que vous aimez
aussi venir avec quelqu'un quand tu
t'entends bien avec le mec est en plus
que ce que le mec fait c'est ça te plaît
enfin tu sais que le morceau il va être
bien en plus toi ça te met enfin moi je
sais que je me mets la pression à chaque
fois que c'est un triste que ça un feat
je veux en fait juste parce que je sais
que le maître qui m'invitent forcément
il il faut que le truc qu'ils soient
bien enfin je veux faire le toit mais là
je suis pas tout seul là il faut je
crois que je n'avais plus la pression
moi avec les fit envoyer vous avez
beaucoup d'achats à poissy mais aussi
dans vos thèmes dans vos sujets qui
reviennent il ya une cité critique
sociétale des quartiers on voit dans le
clip plus ou moins
sympa un peu de la société du quartier
ouais ça parle un petit peu ça parle un
petit peu de tout en fait c'est ça le
truc c'est que moi ça me fait un saint
brès storming mon truc c'est vraiment ça
peut partir dans tous les sens c'est
pour ça que je peux pour aider culture
pop à n'importe quel coin de rue parce
qu'en même temps moi ma vie elle est un
peu celle où tu vois donc les magasins
sont un peu bizarre il ouvre à des
heures un peu celle où je tape des trucs
un peu bon qui sont pas à la commune et
man dans le rad habitué des magasins et
novatel moi je peux faire à ouvrir le
magasin oui mais la trappe il parle à
tout le monde pourtant en tout cas il
parle à beaucoup de gens il parle à
beaucoup de plus de choc je ne pensais
déjà mais en fait je pense que je sais
même pas si c'est bon je sais même pas
si c'est mon peu ras qui parle aux gens
ou si c'est juste le fait de se dire ah
ça fait du bien de voir un mec qui juste
cette fois il tient pas compte de
nouveaux justice ont ils sont fous
chanter c'est la dèche lâchement vous
avez un détachement en fête et du coup
les
je suis pas dans une démarche de
séduction vis-à-vis des gens
avant pas
et ça a l'air de leur plaire et tant
mieux parce que tant mieux ça me permet
de rester moi même moi je sais pas faire
autre chose donc c'est parfait et le
prisme yvelinois durable justement vous
avez des liens avec d'autres rappeurs
des yvelines comment vous moi le vrai
lien que j'ai avec des rappeurs
yvelinois c'est avec une expression
directe avec widi d'expression directe
mais c'est pareil c'est mais s'aimer
gonfler sa saison après celui de donner
la culture du rap et où j'ai un énorme
respect pour tous ces trucs mais des
fois c'est chaud j'ai un énorme respect
mais moi ça me fasse moi ça me va ça me
va à fond mais meiway hormis hormis papa
oui disent est vrai que tout ce qui est
à tiques bosch par exemple qui émarge
aujourd'hui a dit qu'il est due cette
nuit ouais [__] je savais même pas de
la merde il ya atik bosch par exemple
aujourd'hui qui émerge vous n'avez pas
de lien avec un nom du tout du tout mais
très bien c'est tout se sait tout et
tout est très bien ah ouais tu perdais
tout le monde se met à écouter ce que
toi tu écoutes un an
pour terminer ce qu'on a droit à un
petit freestyle en exclusivité allez à
vos avants avant qu'elles soient
périmées celle là encore un peu drôle et
donc on va rajouter un petit but en
derrière mais bon je suis pas sûr aussi
passer un cap et là je sais bien qu'à
plus la
witch qu'est-ce qui se passe tu auras
beau tu lâches et pourra jamais ce qu'il
faut sous le palais pour le bois fait
même l'ajout de manu tu trouves claqué
pour cacher à t'écouter talent et chrome
et a les crocs des loups du jour d'après
et et tout ce qui a plus fait le tour et
vous réussir le casse du siècle ça
suffirait pas pour trash they want it
chez qu'est ce qui se passe
alors pris pour mon grade je crois
qu est ce qui se passe en fait c'est
votre signature qu'est ce cmj mx1
maintenant c'est devenu mon dieu en fait
c'est le truc que je faisais tout le
temps avant et on finit son mais
freestyle en mode si tu dis bonjour
avant de commencer j'avais pas démarrer
en mode haut de ses 5 pour habituer les
gens je vous préviens je vais pas une
boîte pitbull laisser passer le teckel
ça veut dire quoi qu'est ce qui se passe
du coup c'est pour annoncer en faute
owen on savoure cette variante aux
particuliers tenaces comme les rappeurs
qu'ils font ça fait ça fait tu vois
avant que ça fasse un truc mois avant
que ça fasse un bon truc fait tiquer ce
qui se
superbe sans en dire trop peut-être un
son qui va sortir bientôt un vous avez
une date où
j'ai énormément de trucs dans les tuyaux
mais
gênant non parce que dans parce que j'ai
pendant les concerts plus tôt par contre
on est vraiment en train de préparer les
concerts la demande vos concerts
d'avant-hier de bon j'imagine que voilà
il sera passé et qu'il aurait été génial
c'était trop bien elle conserve
d'avocats c'est trop bien si le demain
là c'était trop fou mais non j'attends
on est en train de préparer les dates de
concerts tout ça est quoi qu'il en soit
dès qu'on les aura on comme une
communion à fond et et j'ai hâte mais la
vengeance est allé proches elle s'écoule
à sa règle 1 à la celle là ces pauvres
hères là on va faire des concerts
attention on attend ça merci beaucoup
d'idées d'avoir été avec nous bon merci
à vous surtout c'est la fin de ce billet
grec paie merci à didier d'inventer un
grand merci à vous y retrouver nous très
prochainement sur tv 78
[Musique]